in five weeks a hundred thousand british
forces will strike sicily southern shore
unfortunately the nazis know of our
intentions
so we're going to play a humiliating
trick on hitler
[Applause]
we have to convince germany that our
target is greece the plan begins in
spain where the corpse will wash up on
shore bearing classified letters
a corpse carrying fake documents
given the fascist network there we could
quite literally float the documents
right into enemy hands
prime minister that's too big a risk the
fate of the world is at stake the plan
is highly impossible
so when can it be ready well what say we
start with the easy part and find
ourselves a corpse
the thing is the germans will scrutinize
at every detail of our fallen man
where are his
he legs be as real as your eye he would
carry a letter from his wife professing
her deep love for him very good
and he would carry her photograph my
contribution to the mission for a seat
at the table
although what if the autopsy reveals he
didn't die of drowning
or if the briefcase is returned to us
without the germans seeing its contents
charles why on earth do you keep poking
holes in our plan i'm preemptively
poking
success depends
on guiding the papers into hitler's
hands
the nightmare marching this way is only
too real in the spanish lately the
germans anywhere near our briefcase we
are in the dark if the enemy is waiting
for us on those beaches
history herself will avert our eyes from
the slaughter
i may vomit
i may vomit with you
in stories of war there is that which is
seen and that which is hidden
in god's name fleming what are you
writing
spy story
in the hidden war the truth
is protected by a bodyguard of lies
its soldiers unseen
prey its heroes unsung
[Music]
this
is our war
[Music]
you